alors elle dit que Picasso c'est un
génie certes mais un génie du mal et
votre livre apparaît comme une sorte de
de procès en révision on va en parler
bonsoir
Picasso alors avant toute chose il y a
une brève de comptoir que j'adore avec
Picasso donc je peux pas m'empêcher de
vous la sortir j'ai gardé pour vous
c'est un mec dans un bistrot qui lit un
Picasso au prix où c'est moi sa place
j'aurais fait un tableau puis j'aurais
arrêté après
alors
ça va ça va donc Olivier vous êtes le
fils de Maya Picasso et de Pierre
widmayeur donc votre vrai nom en fait au
départ c'est Olivier villemayeur et puis
en 86 j'ai décidé de prendre le nom de
Picasso pourquoi la loi langue selon le
nom d'usage est passé et donc comme tous
les Français on a le droit de porter le
nom de son père et le nom de sa mère ce
qui est mon cas depuis 17 ans alors
votre mère Maya c'était la fille de
Picasso et de Marie-Thérèse Walter vous
vous êtes juriste de formation au départ
et puis vous êtes producteur notamment
de Yannick Noah pour ce qui concerne la
musique je l'ai été vous avez arrêté là
ça coûte cher alors au bout d'un moment
un succès de flop on arrive vite mais
c'est pas con d'avoir arrêté maintenant
qui vend des disques ah oui mais entre
temps il y a eu quelques flops pour les
autres ah d'accord et puis vous êtes
aussi consultant auprès de la Picasso
administration qui gère l'héritage
Picasso et qui est dirigé par Claude
Picasso c'est une structure qui qui
permet à Claude d'administrer bien tous
les droits de reproduction
tous les droits qui sont attachés aux
oeuvres au nom et à l'image de mon
grand-père Picasso vous dites vous-même
dans le bouquin dont on va parler
d'ailleurs Pablo est mort mais Picasso
est éternel probablement oui alors c'est
vrai qu'on a à gérer aujourd'hui des
éléments qui sont plutôt matériel mais
en fin de compte l'essentiel c'est son
œuvre et c'est ce qu'on essaye de
protéger en essayant d'éviter les
problèmes vous lui ressemblez un peu à
Picasso j'ai le nez c'est vrai
alors voilà donc le bouquin s'appelle
Picasso portrait de famille et cette
édité chez Ramsey
[Musique]
alors ps429 vous dites dans toutes les
familles il existe des secrets des
non-dits chez les Picasso tout a été
révélé pas vraiment finalement parce que
quand on lit votre bouquin on apprend
encore plein de trucs qu'on savait pas
j'ai voulu finalement remettre les
pendules à l'heure parce que depuis très
longtemps tout est rendu public on
raconte tel ou telle chose et puis à la
fin les rumeurs prennent le pas sur sur
la vérité et puis de fil en aiguille on
en arrive à des portraits qui sont un
peu déformés mais qui sont pas la vérité
c'est vrai Olivier il faut dire les
choses tout ce qui a été révélé jusqu'à
maintenant c'est pas extrêmement positif
que ça soit son épouse François Gillot
que ce soit votre
cousine sa petite fille Marina Picasso
ils ont pas fait des portraits très
élogieux de Pablo mais le portrait de
François Gillot était presque une
nécessité historique sans elle on ne
saurait pas tout ce qui serait passé
après la guerre l'engagement politique
la découverte de la Côte d'Azur et je
pense que son livre a fait beaucoup de
bruit pour rien et beaucoup de mal pour
rien comme je l'ai dit parce que elle
n'y révèle absolument rien de déplacer
et puis à votre cousine Marina on se
demande je vous dis la vérité on se
demande si ce livre n'est pas seulement
finalement au fond qu'une réponse à
Marine c'était la cerise sur le gâteau
mais le gâteau elle l'a aussi et c'était
un peu difficile d'abord de coécrire un
livre et je pense que son co-auteur a
donné beaucoup plus de l'irismes et elle
essaie de côté à mon avis une certaine
une certaine vérité alors elle dit que
Picasso c'est un génie certes mais un
génie du mal et votre livre apparaît
comme une sorte de de procès en révision
on va en parler alors Marina Picasso
était notre invité il y a à peu près un
an d'ailleurs presque jour pour jour et
voilà ce qu'elle disait en parlant de
ces visites à Picasso votre grand-père
magnéto Serge alors ce qu'elle peut
touchante dans votre dans votre bouquin
ce qui est vraiment fou les larmes aux
yeux il faut dire les choses c'est les
visites du jeudi quand votre père avance
comme ça vers la grille de la de la
Californie qui est la propriété donc
habiter Picasso vous habitez aujourd'hui
il arrive quoi avec ses enfants sa femme
pour voir son père et il est renvoyé par
le concierge on lui ouvre pas la porte
on lui dit le maître travail le maître
d'or oui c'est à l'époque où il vivait
avec Jacqueline sa dernière épouse et
c'est vrai qu'elle mettait des barrières
et on n'était pas reçu spontanément et
c'était souvent très difficile alors
Jacqueline dit le soleil ne veut pas
qu'on le dérange
elle surnommait mon grand-père le soleil
le Dieu bon parce qu'elle le prenait
pour
j'allais dire pour quelque chose pour
quelqu'un de surhumain donc c'était
qualificatifs et elle admirait tant
qu'elle le traité de la sorte voilà donc
c'était il y a un an dans tout le monde
en parle d'ailleurs dans votre livre
page 39 vous ne n'y pas Olivier Picasso
vous dites effectivement mon grand-père
était un roi soleil un astre dominateur
dont les femmes étaient les planètes
satellites je pense qu'il fallait vivre
avec Picasso sans Picasso ou par Picasso
c'est à partir de là que certains ont
vécu par Lui et se sont probablement
noyés et à partir du moment où le
dialogue était rompu il n'avait plus de
raison de vivre ou de raison d'aller
voir ailleurs
voyez à quoi vous avez échappé vous
d'avoir des parents qui avaient pas de
blé c'est un peu l'histoire de tout tout
c'est génial et vous les gens connus les
célébrités vous avez intérêt de faire
gaffe parce que peut-être que vous
pouvez partir dans cette direction
alors dans son livre Marina Picasso
parle de son père
alors Picasso lui remettait l'argent au
compte-goutte il obligé à venir mendier
l'argent chez lui d'une certaine façon
c'est à dire qui était entretenu par son
père donc il n'avait pas d'indépendance
pécuniaire donc il devait passer par ses
caprices pour vivre convenablement oui
de détruit donc comme je l'ai dit
alcoolique cancer du foie ça vous énerve
de voir ça oh ça m'ennuie d'imaginer que
le livre de ma cousine a des morceaux
qui manquent parce que elle oublie de
raconter probablement les relations
entre son père et sa mère et le divorce
de ses parents sa mère et millienne a eu
la guerre d'exclusive des enfants et
rien n'était prévu pour le père donc on
peut imaginer tout ce que ça engendre
comme conséquence d'autre part on
regarde l'argent Paul était un Paul
Picasso donc le premier fils de mon
grand-père était un joyeux un joyeux
gileron c'était quelqu'un de heureux
toutes les personnes que j'ai
rencontrées beaucoup ont toutes dit la
même chose c'était un homme pas
compliqué heureux de vivre qui avait des
rapports avec son père qui était tout à
fait particulier et au niveau de
l'argent sans perdre lui donner
ABSOLUMENT ce qu'il voulait enfin il y a
une chose malheureusement enfin vous
allez nous dire si c'est vrai mais il y
a quelque chose de d'atroce dans le
bouquin de Marina Picasso
c'est la mort de son frère Pablito
magnéto Serge alors Picasso meurt à
l'âge de 92 ans deux jours plus tard
votre grand frère pardon Pablito
il va devant les grilles de la maison il
est renvoyé et on l'accepte pas qui
rentre dans cette maison alors que son
grand-père venait de mourir il absorbe
de l'eau de javel et ce qui est terrible
c'est que faute d'argent on peut pas
l'emmener dans un hôpital à Marseille et
il agonise pendant 90 jours pendant
trois mois à l'hôpital de La Fontonne à
Antibes
et on n'a pas pu le sauver je pense
qu'on aurait pas pu le sauver davantage
mais on a même pas pu tenter cette
chance Olivier là aussi un contexte
tableau que Picasso 92 ans seul dans
l'atelier recule son art complètement
imaginons un homme de 92 ans c'est pas
un jeune homme de 20 ans et puis ce
cousin qui s'appelait Pablo Picasso lui
aussi et qu'on a appelé très vite
Pablito et qui probablement avait des
raisons bien plus profondes qu'une
simple grille qui s'est fermée ce
jour-là il est vrai que l'année d'avant
il y avait eu un petit scandale il avait
voulu essayer de mettre à la maison le
gardien ne connaissant pas lui avait pas
ouvert il était passé par-dessus la
grille et Pablo qui à l'époque avait 91
ans c'était avait été effrayé mais c'est
pas lui qui tenait les clés c'est pas
lui qui répondait à l'interphone et je
pense qu'à un enchaînement de
circonstances qui ont fait et qu'il a
été conduit à la plus grande détresse
alors faut dire quand même c'est vrai
qu'autour de Pablo Picasso il y a eu
quand même une certaine hécatombe
il suicide de Pablito on vient d'en
parler le père polo on l'a dit
alcoolique mort d'un cancer du foie
Marie-Thérèse Walter qui s'est pendu
dans son garage quand même bon votre
grand-mère
Jacqueline Roque qui s'étire une balle
dans la tête ça fait beaucoup quand même
non oui mais on peut pas dire que mon
grand-père était le responsable de morts
qui sont survenus après sa propre mort
par contre en ce qui concerne
Marie-Thérèse et Jacqueline je pense ça
s'inscrivait dans la logique de leur
relation application elle avait vécu par
lui uniquement comme vous le disiez
Jacqueline appelé Pablo Monseigneur
c'était un discours amoureux entre une
femme qui avait une trentaine d'années
et un homme que
et donc leur mort s'inscrit dans une
dimension presque théâtrale leur vie
avait été quelque chose d'exceptionnel
leur mort l'a été également alors avec
Marina les problèmes pour vous ont
commencé au moment de la faire Citroën
magnéto Serge alors bon quand il y a
l'histoire de Citroën qui rachète le nom
de Picasso vous ça vous effondré comment
des gens dans tellement d'argent
peuvent-ils avant de leur nom
pour de l'argent mais moi je l'ai appris
par la presse comme tout le monde j'ai
fait un procès à ma famille et j'étais
déboutée parce que j'étais la seule à
vouloir annuler ce contrat donc voilà
maintenant aujourd'hui je suis devant un
fait accompli bon mais je ne peux plus
rien faire mais moi j'ai essayé de faire
quelque chose je trouve ça triste
quelques petites choses
d'abord les problèmes n'ont pas commencé
là avec marinez on commence il y a plus
de 20 ans elle vous dira peut-être
pourquoi elle ne vient plus réunion de
famille mais il faut dire qu'il y a 20
ans la préinitiative malheureuse elle
avait vendu les droits de l'indivision à
une société américaine c'est la ferme
Golberg il a fallu 15 années pour
redresser les choses et remettre un
petit peu la situation en état d'autre
part si on veut être très clair elle n'a
pas fait un procès pour faire annuler le
contrat elle a fait un procès pour que
je sois personnellement exclu de cette
affaire et donc c'était une affaire de
grossou avant tout et troisièmement le
contrat qui était passé extrudé ça se
crée dans une logique depuis de
nombreuses années le nom de Picasso est
devenu une marque mais pas par notre
fête la famille n'a jamais voulu faire
de marchandising par le fait qu'il y a
eu des dépôts de marque dans le monde
entier qu'un moment donné on est arrivé
à 700 marques illégales qui auraient
donné lieu à des centaines de produits
que nous ne souhaitions pas des
sous-vêtements des casseroles des
ventilateurs Picasso qu'on a découvert
en Extrême-Orient vous dites qu'en
Espagne vous avez vu un foulard pas un
paru trio et signé Picasso exactement
sortir du musée de la de la reine Sophie
où se trouve Guernica alors il faut il
faut un petit peu contrôler les choses
et la logique de d'autoriser Citroën à
avoir une licence et non pas une vente
l'essence du nom de Picasso c'est
simplement une façon de lutter contre
les problèmes de piratage pourquoi une
Citroën Xsara pourquoi pas une belle
caisse
parce que il faut d'abord faire un choix
de celui avec lequel on va faire un
contrat et que Citroën André Citroën un
grand ingénieur du 20e siècle dans le
public c'est la mémoire collective qui
fait que Citroën c'est d'accord
on se demande si votre bouquin au-delà
d'une réponse à Marina finalement c'est
pas une entreprise pour protéger la
marque parce que si le génie est
considéré comme un génie du mal la
marque sera peut-être moins vache à lait
que ce qu'elle peut l'être dans l'autre
cas j'avais absolument aucune démarche
commerciale quand j'ai fait ce livre
c'était vraiment pour mettre les choses
au point mais de façon radicale à l'aide
de témoignage à l'aide de documents
irréfutables alors vous savez qu'ici
donc on est votre cousine donc marina et
puis on est aussi Alice magnéto Serge
alors une question maintenant un mail de
Thierry Ardisson
Alice Evans comment vivez-vous votre
séparation avec Olivier Picasso je
pensais que vous allez attendre un petit
peu avant de poser cette question mais
non pas du tout pas du tout
vous êtes prêtes à répondre je peux
répondre oui mais je donne des temps
pour réfléchir maintenant j'ai bien
réfléchi je vis ça très mal comme toutes
ces séparation c'est très dur vous devez
8 ans de vie commune on est très amis et
voilà parfois la vie n'est pas facile et
les choses ne vont pas comment voudrais
et c'était le cas et je pense à lui tous
les jours et je l'appelle très souvent
elle est magnifique et je dois dire
qu'on a une relation tellement
exceptionnelle presque fusionnelle je
vois pas comment est-ce qu'elle pourrait
disparaître de ma vie
c'est quelqu'un à qui je pense tous les
jours et le temps nous a probablement
éloigné son métier de comédienne nous a
aussi éloigné mais ça reste quelqu'un
qui est dans mon cœur probablement pour
toujours vous avez quelque chose à lui
dire de particulier là profitez-en parce
que je sais que les missions qu'elle
reste comme elle est belle et
intelligente merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'ai une idée
j'ai une idée on va voir si vous savez
dessiner Picasso et oui est-ce que vous
pouvez aller sur la scène
[Musique]
attention interview dessiner c'est gagné
alors est-ce qu'on peut me dessiner en
haut à droite une fleur s'il vous plaît
vous allez voir que le génie se transmet
pas
j'ai eu du mal peut-être j'ai mis deux
dessiner s'il vous plaît Olivier un
mouton
un petit mouton là je m'enfonce très
très bien avant on voit bien mais c'est
bien très bien
alors maintenant est-ce que vous me
dessiner un portrait avec les yeux et
les oreilles du même côté
c'est bizarre mais bon pareil ça
rapporte du pognon avec les yeux et les
oreilles du même côté les yeux et les
oreilles même côté je sais que c'est dur
ah oui pour un juriste c'est la partie
les yeux et les oreilles du même côté
comme un vrai Picasso que vous êtes
bien bravo bravo
c'est bien
[Musique]
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez maintenant
s'il vous plaît signer ce cadre qui est
à moi
Picasso marqué Picasso je m'arrangerai
mais écrire à l'envers ça va être dur
voilà vous mettez Picasso voilà
il est pour moi
merci beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu